[Upbeat music playing]
Here we are sharing a meal like we are used to
doing so very often in our daily lives.
But what we might not always realize is that along with
our own efforts at preparing the various foods
other living entities play hugely important roles
in making the foods we serve not only edible but
nutritious and simply delicious.
These living
entities we do not normally perceive as beingalive.
These are the microbes that over millennia
have transformed many ingredients turning them
into such delightful food and drink as bread
cheese, beer, and wine and many many others.
So for thousands and thousands of years humans
have been taking advantage of microbial growth
to ferment and preserve their foods.
But it is not all just about food preservation,
fermented foods are safe to eat but they can also
provide entirely new textures and flavors making
them thoroughly enjoyable to consume.
So welcometo the marvelous world of microbial foods.